the topic for this video lecture is
connected vertices the kind of
connections we can have between
different vertices edges so we're gonna
start by showing that the shortest walk
between two vertices is a path now we're
going to prove it by contradiction so
suppose we have some path from u to B
and it crosses over itself right so here
we have U and V and at some point you
know you get to C then you go back to C
and from there you go to V right so
you've gone through the Vord some virtus
C twice but if you want to get the
shortest path from u to V why would you
go through this loop why not just keep
going straight from C to B so the path
with that you know that section that
goes from C back to itself also goes
from u to be and is shorter so if we
have any path that crosses over itself
we can just get rid of that part that
loops around back into itself and we
still have a a walk from u to V so
therefore the shortest walk we need to
be is going to be a path so now we're
going to talk about the length n walk
relation what this means is with two
vertices V and W there is this GN
relation between V and W if there is
there exists a length and walk from V to
W and GN is called the length n walk
relation for G so basically if you can
find a way to go from V to W in exactly
n steps then GN applies from V to W and
G itself when you think about it is the
length one walk walk relation you know
the graphs define these relations and
there's an edge from one virtus to
another if there's if there's a length
of one edge from one vertex to another
you know it is it's tough now this lemma
right we say that GM and relational
composition with GN equals G M plus n
let's explain what this means so what
that relational composition means is
that that really the relational
composition between the two applies from
X to Y
if there is some virtus Z such that
there is a path M from X to Z and then a
path ñ from Z to one right there's some
GN replies from X to Z and GN applies
from Z to Y and Y this is the same thing
as G and plus in makes sense right if
there's a path length m to Z and on the
path left Glen's end from there to Y you
just go from X to Z and M steps then Z 2
y n steps and you have n plus n steps
from X to Y the length 0 walk relation
just makes each virtus go back to itself
like it points back to itself the
individual one and the lemma still true
you know G 0 composed with G n is just G
n which makes sense you know everything
itself plus GN just gives you G
let's talk about composition of matrices
so if we have some adjacency matrix for
G then and we do a composition with some
H then we can get that by applying this
boolean and/or matrix multiplication you
know these adjacency matrices are ones
and zeros so we do matrix multiplication
but with boolean operations instead of
plusses and multiplications so we can
compute a G of n by fast matrix
exponentiation how do we do that well
basically you can do it for G and over
to twice and then GN over 4 for each of
those twice and go doing those boolean
operations on each right so a G of n
equals a G of n over 2 applying this
operator to a G n over 2 so you can just
break it down into each time so we get
logarithmic number of products that we
have to do
now let's define another relation g-star
is just called the walk relation of G
and basically you a G Star applies from
u to V if there is a walk for me to be
no matter how long it is if you can find
some way to get from u to B then in a
but if we want to get the walk relation
you just get everything inside the the
graph and apply self-loop so make every
ad in a edge that points back to itself
for every virtus and we call this G less
than or equal to and it's basically G
and then add in these G 0 self birds
self edges and G less than equal to has
a length and walk if G has a less than
or equal to n1 now think about that if I
can get from virtus x2 virtus y in n
minus 1 or n minus some amount of steps
in G then I can get there in n steps in
G less than or equal to because I can
just loop around right if I want to get
here from red to blue right I can get
there in one step without those self
loops but with the self loops I can just
keep starting from red go around to read
as many times as I want n minus 1 times
and then do this final step so I can
make it make a n length and walk for any
value of N greater than me now let's
compute the walk relation using what
we've just defined so G has n vertices
so the length of path are gonna be less
than or equal to n right if you go if we
just go in a straight line from one
thing to another passing through each
possible produce at most you're gonna
get n minus 1 length right because
you're gonna pass through n vertices so
there's n minus 1 edges connected so G
star which is just the relation if there
is a walk from you to B is going to be
this G less than or equal to 2 the N
minus 1 so if we get G less than or
equal to add in all these self loops and
then find all the paths of length
this one in there which is basically all
paths and a G Star and G less than equal
to n minus 1 is all path less than or
equal to n minus 1 but since G only has
passed of less than or equal to n minus
1 that's just all the pads it's just
every single one of the verse and so
we've defined G Star and that's how we
get all connected bird espares and we
can do this in n squared log n time
using that composition of the Jason C
matrices